[Music]
okay let's do this so just a little
background
I'm from Sims if it's my company I'm
wearing a t-shirt whoo-hoo but let me
show you we are sin for base in the
Philippines this is our team we're kind
of wacky but we do websites and mobile
apps for clients so we do a lot of
projects so we have a lot of projects
over here we have a lot of clients and
so for every single client or for every
single project we build it on App Engine
we put a code and bitbucket and someone
has to do this fork a boilerplate in the
repository grant user permissions create
a GCP project create App Engine
application set up deployment
configuration repeat these steps again
for the test environment and that's
usually falls on me the CTO so I've been
doing that again and again almost like
once every week or twice every week and
it's really getting tiring so we also
use slack a lot so we thought what if we
can initialize and deploy GCP projects
from slack Wow
so we did just that so it's demo time so
here we go so to make it more exciting
I'm gonna play some epic background
music that I got from YouTube
royalty-free just letting you know okay
there all right so what we do is we just
type Sims but help
that's our bot and slack and it tells me
all the things I can do including this
create project project ID region which
will then initialize a project so I
wrote this documentation I didn't expect
that you will have to read it on stage
from some stage so that's a lot of words
right there don't have to read it but
let's try that so I type create project
let's go
Zim's next demo let's just put the 19
hit enter and so now it's creating a
production environment a test project as
well and it's doing that it's working
the repository and doing that now
I asked that's all the time what do you
do when you you're waiting for things
that are loading what's the time you
just browse you know you open another
tab browse Facebook and then 30 minutes
later you're still on Facebook so what I
tell people to do you do push-ups yeah
so we're done
[Music]
[Applause]
alright so the good thing about this
it's it's it important if it fails I can
actually do the same command again and
try it this time with fingers crossed
I'm assuming that so many people are
doing projects in the code labs and I
don't know maybe that it's delaying I
really have no idea I should do push-ups
again
all right okay so second time it aired I
don't know what's happening really
it says permissions error fetching
application but if we go over here it
should have the the project in the
console oh resource manager projects get
okay so it didn't create the project I
don't know why let's try to create a
project manually this work when I
practice Oh Google should give me more
quota so maybe we created too many
projects who too quickly because we're
doing this on slack and we ran out
alright so I'll continue with the
presentation I'll just show you how it's
actually supposed to be a round of
applause please
okay so let's just imagine it works and
I reduced my background music so when we
tape type of command in slack for a
project it sends a message to our bot
you know a slack boy can be any slap but
that you have and then it sends a post
request to our App Engine app I'll go
over the code in a little bit it acts as
a coordinators why it does its first it
Forks the boilerplate in bitbucket
then it prays the project's enable
services like vision API datastore API
API so we commonly use and they it also
supports a deployment for our deployment
service that's also running compute
engines the custom script obviously we
can do this on you know Klaus reports
repositories and also cloud build but
for now running it on a custom
deployment script on compute engine so
where where is all of this it's in this
link and I'll go over the code right now
and I apparently I can't click on this
thing so I'll type it up github since
the Simcoe slash GCP slack in it how am
i doing on time alright so I'm gonna go
just be free over the code I'm assuming
most of your developers so here these
are the things you need to put in this
is public and open source it's one oh
it's my first open source project that
I'm releasing to devs like you so please
be kind I know some of these are
supposed to be in end and not committed
but I did so yeah don't don't put it and
get up when you deploy it on your own ok
so you have your just put these things
in and what it does is when it when you
this is what runs when you hit the end
point from the slack bot so first it
does you know it Forks the repo from
bitbucket and then it adds the branch
merge permission so that you know we
have customers in the company right now
people can delete the branch where
people can delete the prajapatis ori
that's really good to put in and then we
create the project in GCP under a
specific folder in our company and in
this case same projects
and then we also do the same thing we
create a test project this time we just
add the word test at the end so it's
sort of like a convention in the company
and then we create App Engine so I
manually add us and sleep for five
seconds because after pics about five
seconds for project creation and then
you can enable the App Engine service
you can choose the region where you put
it you essential-1 Asia is - we like
that poster from the Philippines and
then we also create App Engine tests
again and then this is the part where we
add it to our custom deployment script
now and then we enable datastore and for
the test project as well and you can add
other services you want to enable here
so basically that's the code base and
it's available in github
feel free to improve it make it better
and hope you find it useful and just
imagine that when I did the whole demo
it was really amazing and I did so much
push-ups and the thing about the
push-ups is that at least if your script
is slow your body is healthy right okay
if your body is not healthy at least
your script is fast
so if you want to connect with me I'm on
LinkedIn and I'm also a my email is up
there I'm happy to share this with
anybody who also wants to you know use
it so that's all thank you very much
[Music]